bonsoir à tous et merci de nous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro de
kiosques que votre émission culturelle
tout de suite le sommaire de ce mercredi
15 juin
après deux représentations sur le bassin
de neptune qui avait conquis 14000
spectateurs en 2009
blanche neige revient dans les jardins
de l'orangerie du château de versailles
pour quatre dates jusqu'à vendredi
créé en 2008 par angelin prejlocaj le
ballet réunis les 24 danseurs permanents
de sa compagnie le groupe illinois
zéphyr lauréat de l'édition inhibante
and the chase 2016 est arrivé premier au
concours de l'ail co organisée par le
conseil départemental des yvelines
cette élection leur permet de se
produire sur la scène du domaine de
madame elisabeth à versailles pour la
fête de la musique mardi 21 juin
françois guillon directeur du théâtre
alphonse daudet 2 coignières nous
rejoindra un plateau dans quelques
instants
il vient nous présenter la programmation
de la prochaine saison artistique du
théâtre de la danse et toujours des
spectacles jeune public et je vous le
disais après deux représentations sur le
bassin de neptune qui avait conquis pas
moins de quatorze mille spectateurs en
le ballet d'angelin preljocaj blanche
neige revient au jardin de l'orangerie
de versailles
quatre dates jusqu'à vendredi on regarde
blanche neige revient en majesté dans
les jardins de l'orangerie jusqu'à
vendredi
ce ballet créé par angelin prejlocaj en
2008 connu un succès international
immédiat et obtient en 2009 le globe de
cristal trailer à la hâte et rama turgis
très riche l'oeuvre est la plus
populaire des 49 création du chorégraphe
c'est une nouvelle façon d'aborder la
danse c'est à dire de vraiment raconté
par le corps par les mouvements une
histoire à raconter chaque événement
parce que tout y est
j'essayais justement de faire une oeuvre
populaire et de mettre tout mon exigence
dans l'écriture chorégraphique pour
rester au niveau quand même le plus haut
par la danse sans descendre à lhassa et
tout en allant quand même vers quelque
chose qui va aussi bien en chanter une
petite fille de 7 ans que que quelqu un
qu un homme de 70 ans qui a découvert sa
voie là
cette parenthèse féerique réunis les 24
danseurs de la compagnie d'angelin
preljocaj
créé en 1985 l'adaptation de l'oeuvre
est resté fidèle à la version du conte
des frères grimm de 1812 un compte
encore très contemporain par ces
thématiques autour de l'image et de la
vieillesse
j'ai trouvé que blanche neige était un
compte absolument moderne parce que de
nos jours avec les projets de les
progrès de la science de la médecine la
diététique la cosmétique aussi ça amène
de cette condition cette situation qui
peut faire naître un problème de deux
conflits autour de la séduction
je crois qu'on est dans l'air un peu du
complexe de blanche-neige presse comme
on dit qu'il ya le complexe d'oedipe on
bat notre époque peut-être génère le
complexe de blanche neige par le fait
que les femmes sont plus libres plus
belle et que leur fille finalement
entrent en conflit
de séduction avec elle par rapport à un
des prétendants blanche-neige partir à
poursuivre sa tournée en corée du sud
fin juin et pour les amateurs des
chorégraphies d'angelin presse locale le
ballet roméo et juliette sera représenté
au théâtre de chaillot fin décembre à
paris et pour continuer cette émission
on reste toujours sur versailles avec le
groupe heavy noise et firent alors avec
moi deux membres de ce groupe aurélien
belin bonsoir et yoann guérin bon
soissons alors le groupe est fier c'est
donc un groupe yvelinois qui a été
fondée en 2013 un groupe de pop rock
racontez nous un peu votre rencontre
artistique 2013 ça s'est fait entre la
batterie avec aurélien mois guitare
chant on avait des projets déjà avant en
fait et on a voulu créer quelque chose
de nouveau repartir sur de nouvelles
bases
dans un style qu'on affectionne pop rock
auquel il ya eu des teintes qui se sont
rajoutés des teintes plus groove avec
les autres musiciens qui nous ont
rejoints en 2014 début 2014 pour le
guitariste valentin vous êtes vraiment
les fondateurs du groupe
c'est ça ouais oui mais vraiment la base
ouais donc le style a un peu évolué ça
fait donc maintenant trois ans que vous
êtes en place que vous répétez de façon
assidue et il faut préciser que vous
êtes les lauréats de l'édition 2007 the
choice qui se déroulèrent à montigny le
bretonneux début janvier et on va
regarder votre prestation
alors donc vous êtes 4 dans le groupe
c'était suite à une résidence artistique
cette édition the chase aurélien suite à
une résidence artistique l'annonça pas
encore été fait on va sûrement faire une
première partie d'un groupe connu suite
a donc à ce concours gagné mais ce sera
donc plutôt en hiver en décembre donc
vous faites aussi bien évoluer la
musique on va dire que toute la
scénographie toute l'unité artistique et
penser on va justement écouter une
interview que nous avions faite à
l'occasion avec votre groupe
on recherche fini 2e dans un cadre
musical entre nous créer une musique de
la musique de ses filles et en même
temps lui ni ton et cherche aussi dans
le visuel parce que c'est pas uniquement
la musique aujourd'hui en musique on a
besoin de visuels c'est très très
important et donc on essaye d'être un
peu de penser on peut surtout les plombs
et yoann cette unité artistique elle est
très importante lorsqu'on fait de la
musique
ouais mais unité artistique je pense que
d'abord sur l'unité humaine aussi qui
est
qui doit être présente c'est ce qu'on a
au sein des filles et je pense que c'est
déjà une bonne base pour nous pour
ensuite jouer on s'entend comme ça on
arrive à s'entendre à se comprendre
aussi musicalement artistiquement et
donc cette unité là forcément humaine va
sur l'artistique après vous êtes devenu
4,4 années on va l'air tout à fait oui
on se sent vraiment très bien c'est très
important pour créer notre musique et on
se voit on se voit très régulièrement
pas que pour faire des répète mais aussi
à d'autres moments donc aurélien vous
nous disiez tout à l'heure
le fait d'avoir gagné l'édition 2016 de
jeu tu êtes vous permettra aux à l'hiver
prochain d'être la première partie d'un
groupe connu mais vous avez également
été sélectionnés d'abord pour participer
au concours organisé par le conseil
départemental des yvelines avec l'espoir
peut-être d'être lauréat de pour
participer à la fête de la musique qui
se tiendra mardi 21 juin au domaine de
madame elisabeth à versailles qui est
spécialement ouvert pour l'occasion donc
expliquez-nous un pouliot nbc une
formidable occasion pour nous de déjà de
nous produire dans ce domaine de madame
elisabeth qui quand même un lieu
historique c'est la première fois que le
département des yvelines ouvre cet
espace où si tardivement et pour des
concerts alors on va revenir juste donc
c'était un concours de l'ail qui se
passait sur facebook parce que là vous
nous dit déjà que quelque part vous êtes
les lauréats du concours alors bravo
vous félicite
bonsoir je veux venir juste un petit peu
en avant donc au final c'est un concours
de l'ail sur facebook mais en fait il ya
eu une sélection de la part du qui a été
fait par le département des yvelines 28
groupes ont été sélectionnés sur les 28
10 en fait là il fallait envoyer les
maquettes exactement une vidéo qui a été
mise en ligne ensuite sur le site
les yvelines les internautes devaient
voilà prononcé leur choix pour tel ou
tel groupe qu'ils appréciaient plus et
les quatre groupes en fait au final qui
m'ont reçu le plus de like
et bien voilà font partie de la
programmation aujourd'hui de cette belle
fête de la musique
alors vous faites donc partie des quatre
groupes qui ont reçu le plus direct mais
vous êtes les premiers vous êtes les
lauréats c'est donc un choix du public
le choix du public c'est le plus
important lorsqu'on est artiste aurélien
oui le choix du public est très
important ça prouve que il aime ce qu'on
fait il aime notre musique est donc nous
c'est ce qu'on veut faire on veut faire
de la musique qui plaît à tout le monde
et voilà que les gens aiment bien bien
pour des moments conviviaux fédérateur
alors faire vous répéter régulièrement
et vous produisez sur différentes scènes
ouvertes l'une des dernières que vous
ayez fait c'était à la clé des champs à
plaisir
le coeur
attention il
l'ess
julie
donc lauréats du concours de l'ail
qu'est organisée par le conseil
départemental des yvelines c'est le
sésame pour se produire sur la scène du
domaine de madame elisabeth 45 minutes
de jeu qu'est ce que vous avez prévu
pour ces 45 minutes aurélien nos
chansons de composition des nouveautés
des ouïes des nouveautés des surprises
et des choses en plus ce qui va se
passer pour être été beaucoup y aurait
oui alors généralement on essaie d'avoir
une certaine discipline essayer de
répéter quand on n'a pas de concert
minimum une fois ou deux fois par
semaine pour travailler des nouveaux
morceaux pour travailler de nouvelles
choses aient évolué et pour ses concerts
là quand il ya des concerts qui arrivent
et notamment des gros événements comme
ça
on travaille beaucoup plus en amont et
on fait beaucoup plus de répèt ouais
alors aurélien se produire sur la scène
du domaine de madame elisabeth son offre
une grosse visibilité ça fait un petit
moment déjà que vous espérez vous
produire sur versailles quel intérêt
pour vous si saab à versailles c'est la
vie la plus importante des yvelines et
on voulait vraiment y jouer et donc
apparemment il y aurait peut-être 2000
personnes qui seraient là donc ça peut
être tout à fait une très belle vitrine
en lien avec les perspectives peut-être
du groupe zéphyr pour la suite
oui oui bah essayer d'avoir la
visibilité c'est important pour nous
pour faire voilà un peu propulsé entre
guillemets le projet
nous nous ce qu'on veut maintenant c'est
enregistré 1,2 pc ce qu'on se fixe pour
d'ici la fin de l'été début septembre
peut-être tourner tourner le plus
possible c'est vraiment notre on adore
s'arrête sur scène allait rencontrer le
public qu'on invite d'ailleurs à aller à
versailles voilà c'est un vrai plaisir
de les rencontrer et puis essayer de
fédérer toujours autour du projet zéphyr
de nouvelles personnes
des personnes qui peuvent nous
accompagner aussi professionnellement
maintenant voilà l'objectif
alors on vous suivra nous serons là
marié 21 juin au domaine de madame
elisabeth à versailles pour vous
retrouver sur scène yoann guérin merci
aurélien de l'inde avoir été sur notre
plateau vous pouvez retrouver toutes les
informations sur le groupe yvelinois
zéphyr à l'adresse qui s'affiche à
l'écran et sans transition quand
certaines villes attendent mardi pour
fêter la fête de la musique d'autres s'y
prépare dès ce week end comme la ville
de trappes
samedi 18 juin donc dès 14 heures
l'école municipale de musique et de
danse ouvre ses portes venez rencontrer
les professeurs et les élèves également
rendez vous samedi 18 juin à partir de
14 heures sur la pelouse du scarabée de
la verrière au programme stands
associatifs des animations des jeux des
débats et des spectacles
la ville de guyancourt également la
batterie tout entière avec maman de cet
espace scénique va raisonner à partir de
samedi dès 18 heures et enfin la ville
de villepreux enflamme la place du
marché de samedi
samedi 18 à partir de 15h et dimanche 19
juin dès 11h la commanderie des
templiers d'elancourt vous présente sa
dernière exposition une exposition qui
s'inscrit toujours dans la thématique
des arts et du numérique avec un artiste
multidisciplinaire eric vernay ce
l'artiste présente ces objets temporel
jusqu'au 3 juillet dix oeuvres au
mouvement narrative des images animées
les créations des ricv renaissent sont
présentés à la commanderie des templiers
architecte de formation eric vernay se
fascine pour le cinéma depuis son plus
jeune âge ou plus exactement pour la
dimension temporelle mise en images par
le procédé cinématographique
je suis dit je vais essayer de faire un
projecteur qui serait fait que pour un
film en quelque sorte un fil au
projecteur lui-même ce serait une
sculpture et puis le film ferait partie
du projecteur en quelque sorte et
l'ensemble fine projecteurs ce serait
une sculpture à part entière est ce ça
fait juste pour ce film là alors j'ai
commencé à réfléchir à cette idée là et
j'en suis venu à faire des coupes
sur avec du temps à l'intérieur c'est à
dire des choses qui bougent en quelque
sorte comme au cinéma
parmi ces objets temps pour elle comme
il les appelle se distingue une oeuvre
réalisée en hommage à epicure
philosophes de l'antiquité qui eut
l'intuition géniale des atomes à
l'origine de toute vie organique
il ya donc des petites billes sur un sur
un plateau qui lorsque l'on n'avance
près de l'oeuvre se met en mouvement
elle s'entrechoquent
elles produisent un bruit et en même
temps il ya notre image qui se dessinent
sur l'écran qui est derrière comme si
c'était cette petite bille représentait
donc les atomes constitutifs de ce don
ce don en effet la plupart des
installations cinétique visuel et sonore
des ricv renaissent sont mis en
mouvement par le spectateur ou des
logiques auto générative une exposition
originale et interactive et vient de
nous rejoindre en plateau françois
guillon bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous êtes le directeur du théâtre
alphonse daudet de coignières et vous
venez nous présenter la saison prochaine
est ce une saison qui va s'inscrire dans
la continuité de la saison précédente
toujours avec des spectacles jeune
public une programmation éclectique où
ce rappel en rupture ce sera tout à fait
dans la continuité mais d'abord je suis
très heureux d'être là parce que depuis
que coignières et dans la communauté de
communes de saint quentin
nous avons la joie de pouvoir présenter
notre travail à ce téléfilm ce qu'on
faisait pas du tout avant et donc le
théâtre alphonse daudet c'est un théâtre
de proximité de 400 places qui est un
qui est un très beau théâtre c'est une
forme de bateau et puis il ya surtout
200 places de parking à proximité donc
on peut vraiment pas dire venir vous
voir vient alors cette programmation
pour la saison prochaine vous rend
continuité c'est à dire musique chant
musique danse théâtre et ce que j'essaye
de trouver dans la programmation c'est
ce que je vous dit tout à l'heure une
résonance contemporaine c'est à dire que
très concrètement sur des problématiques
contemporaines c'est à dire par exemple
au niveau du thé
j'ai choisi par exemple le faiseur de
balzac parce que ça traite du sujet de
la crise financière de retrouvent tout
le problème de la dette financière dans
ce texte de balzac
alors le faiseur de balzac ce sera le
mardi 4 octobre à 20h45
c'est une comédie un peu grinçant qui
est représenté par les tréteaux de
france
alors les tréteaux de france c'est un
peu pour moi le pour le théâtre le
modèle c'est à dire si c'est du théâtre
qui était créée par jean d'années il ya
très longtemps
et puis qui a été repris par marcel
maréchal c'est un théâtre de troupe et
c'est un petit peu ce qu'on fait au
théâtre alphonse daudet six étapes de
trous rien d'ailleurs inter douala iii
prix que tu as fait et on va regarder
tout de suite un extrait d'ettiler seule
étape en europe qui n'est en printemps
n'est pas volée dire j'y joue le mot
n'est pas parlementaire que vous pouvez
faire le bien mais ce que vous pouvez
faire de mal ne s'agit pas d'avoir des
talents et de virer alors un autre
spectacle qui va être présentée
également dans votre théâtre qui va
mêler aussi bien la danse le théâtre le
mime servi par huit danseurs hip hop ce
sera bardot neige et les sept petits
cochons au bois dormant c'est du théâtre
jeune public ça n'a pas du tout c'est de
la danse c'est un spectacle de danse
contemporaine et hip hop
donc c'est le même principe c'est à dire
que avec à partir des contes de grimm et
bien la modernité c'est la danse hip hop
et c'est ce que fait laura scozzi qui
est une chorégraphe merveilleuse et caf
qui a monté ce spectacle avec beaucoup
d'humour donc un peu décalé très déjanté
sur mes spectacles de danse hip hop
proposé par le théâtre de suresnes alors
on va regarder également un extrait
alors des spectacles des reprises pour
la saison prochaine au théâtre alphonse
doté mais également des spectacles de
création notamment une qui sera
représenté le samedi 3 décembre à 17
heures et c'est une création de votre
théâtre
oui on a la chance nous d'avoir une
équipe artistique permanente
c'est-à-dire des comédiens on a trois
comédiens professionnels on a une
chorégraphe professionnel et on crée des
spectacles on n'a pas de résidence mais
on crée nous mêmes des spectacles et on
mélange les quelques amateurs et les
professionnels et pour ce théâtre en
route vers champignac laon mais là on
mettra des enfants des écoles
dans ce spectacle donc c'est un mélange
de professionnels et d'amateurs et les
enfants joueront leur propre rôle
c'est-à-dire des des élèves qui vont en
voyage scolaire à champignac et on
transpose raza dans les années 60
ce sera donc en route vers champignac
samedi 3 décembre à 17 heures et enfin
un requiem un requiem le samedi 25 mars
18h et dimanche 26 mars 17h le requiem
de fauré qui serait interprétée par l'
orchestre symphonique
alphonse daudet l'ensemble vocal de
l'énéide voilà là encore nous avons
depuis qu'est ce que 15 ans un orchestre
symphonique à demeure à résidence en
résidence avec des musiciens amateurs et
qui renforçait avec des musiciens
professionnels qui est dirigée par
françois feuillet et chaque année on
monte un concert de qualité cette année
donc c'est le requiem de magnifiques
requiem de fauré avec la chorale de
l'énéide de mort toc qui viendra chanter
bien sûr alors nous n'avons pas le temps
bien sûr de préciser toutes les dates
mais toutes les dates sont à retrouver
sur votre site internet à l'adresse qui
s'affiche à l'écran
merci françois guillon de la soirée
parmi nous aujourd'hui pour nous
présenter la prochaine saison artistique
du théâtre alphonse daudet de coignières
et on parle à présent littérature avec
dominique jean labroue hier cheuvreux
taille père fondateur du parc naturel de
la haute vallée de chevreuse qui nous
livre son dernier roman sans effraction
sur fond de mystère et de romance ce
thriller entraîne le lecteur dans une
farandole mêlant sites naturels et
historiques aux interrogations de
châtelaine inquiète lé trafic d'oeuvres
d'art sur les acteurs locaux
ce roman est une fiction qui se passe
dans les châteaux d'eau
la haute vallée de chevreuse etc
limitant relève le côté fragile du parc
naturel régional
l'auteur nous en parle moi je suis un
des pères fondateurs du parc naturel
régional la voiture eux la veille sur
eux c'est une toute petite région qui
touche la ville ici d'ailleurs à saint
quentin est en fait qui est protégé et
de manière presque artificielle donc en
écrivant ce livre c'est mon troisième
livre en écrivant ce roman je montre la
vallée heureuse sa fragilité
j'essaie de montrer aux gens que c'est
bon et qu'il faut y venir et en même
temps y'a une fiction mais peut-être que
le personnage principal c'est la vallée
de chevreuse et on poursuit à présent
avec votre rubrique septième art tout de
suite vos réactions sur les films à
l'affiché cette semaine c'est un
thriller assez haletant bien tourner
l'histoire
bon c'est classique mais c'est bien joué
c'est à voir c'est un très bon film
banal quand codé bbd sur la dune ses
livres c'est tout à fait lui c'est très
bien c'est dans le monde du makila c'est
un peu pourri mais bon mais il faut
aller le voir surtout pour la femme et
pour le coup de coeur du professionnel
de ce mercredi 15 juin c'est luc
beaucoup ont dû signer c'est d'elancourt
le coup de coeur du ciné cette semaine
une fois n'est pas coutume c'est un film
cubain qui s'appelle xala une enfance
cubaine qui est proposée sur nos écrans
version originale donc c'est un très
beau film rare parce que le cinéma
cubain on connaît pas beaucoup de
réalisateurs cubain on sait que c'est un
pays qui est en train de sourire qui est
en train de se modifier qui est en train
de modifier son mode de vie son mode de
fonctionnement qui s'ouvre à
l'international etc
et là on assiste à une histoire très
réaliste très bien joué par un jeune
acteur cubain qui est un peu délaissé sa
mère est défaillante et c'est lui qui
pourvoit en fait aux besoins de la
famille en élevant des chiens de combat
voilà j'en dis pas plus je vous laisse
découvrir le film c'est une petite perle
les critiques sont dithyrambiques si
vous ouvrez la presse cinéma vous verrez
éblouissant etc etc
c'est vraiment à découvrir dans nos
salles sur nos écrans cette semaine
la conséquence
bingo
je voulais aussi faire un petit focus
sur le cycle martin scorsese puisque
vous pourrez assister si vous vous
intéressez à segré aux grands
réalisateurs qui est martin scorsese
dimanche à 17h30 à une conférence animée
par rijkaard munoz qui viendra nous
parler de l'oeuvre de scorsese et vous
assisterez à 18h30 à la projection en
version originale sous-titrée français
bien évidemment des nerfs à vif un des
films de martin scorsese voilà pour
cette semaine et dont l'univers
cinématographique pourquoi ne pas
s'intéresser également aux films de
patrimoine
l'ugc ciné-cité skywest organise
régulièrement des projections de films
anciens pour redécouvrir le patrimoine
du septième art alors retrouvé drive de
nicolas winding avec ryan gosling le 16
juin à 20 heures
vous pourrez retrouver également le 20
juin le 23 juin à 20h soudain l'été
dernier avec elizabeth taylor
oui
et enfin retrouvé blue velvet de david
lynch le 30 juin à 20 heures
boniface fixe maintien
un terrain coin
c
et le molière continue tout au long du
mois de juin sur versailles alors au
programme un débat par la comédie
française pour retracer le débat qui a
opposé molière à la critique sur donjons
est arthur ce sera demain jeudi 16 juin
à 20h30
également samedi 18 juin retrouvez les
trois soeurs scénario original de la
commedia dell'arte librement inspiré du
don juan de molière
une comédie de carlo boso samedi 18 juin
à 16 heures au square jean ou don de
versailles et c'est déjà la fin de cette
émission merci de nous avoir suivis vous
pourrez la voir et les revoir sur notre
site internet pour ma part je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée et vous
retrouve la semaine prochaine